starting IVs can be really daunting at  first and they take a lot of practice  now one thing that I had a problem with  whenever I was first starting out was  that I would hit the vein but I couldn't  Advance the cannula so what I figured  out that I was doing wrong was that I  wasn't inserting that needle far enough  in that vein before I went to slide off  the cannula so what you want to do is  you want to hit that vein get that blood  return in that chamber then you just  want to slightly insert that needle just  a little bit more in that vein about two  millimeters which is the thickness of a  nickel and then you want to slide off  that cannula and it should slide with  ease into that vein